what's going on guys this is rob and we
are
back with the immortal hulk yes we are
red god hulk versus
thor or the avengers i'm not really sure
what i'm gonna call it yet but this is
basically like the most powerful version
or not i wouldn't say the most powerful
version but it's a super powerful
version of the whole
i think he's incredibly powerful the
biggest issue with this is we don't
really get like a world war hulk
storyline with him but it is really
really cool uh what this does
those of you guys who recall the red god
hulk if we want to call him that
it's like savage hulk just pulsing with
red hulk energy uh had essentially come
up against the ufos now the ufos as we
talked about the previous video that we
did for those of you guys who were
catching up were basically
long time enemies of the incredible hulk
but had recently been contacted by peter
geyrick of course guyrick basically
being like a government agent who was a
longtime foe of the x-men and is now
kind of being invoked here so marvel's
obviously turning him into one of these
guys we just kind of circulate him
around based on the nature of the story
i'm surprised to see him in here but the
ufos have always proven to be pretty
capable with regards to the incredible
hulk the biggest thing that always set
the ufos back is they would bicker
amongst each other and that would
basically give hulk the opportunity to
take them out in this instance
like literally red god hulk just crushes
these guys and it's not even not even a
contest
and they do everything they can even
vapor's helpless and vapor's arguably
the most powerful member of the ufos now
as you guys have probably figured out
vapor's ability is to basically turn
into pretty much any gas and it doesn't
even have to be a gas that you find on
earth it can be a gas from like
extraterrestrial landscapes or anything
like that and it's kind of crazy because
she literally turns into sulfuric acid
gas right which
should be enough to like dissolve the
incredible hulk to give you guys
perspective on what we're dealing with
here sulfuric acid can dissolve metals
right usually charge it but it could
dissolve metals right you just break
them down if you had
if you have like water or alcohol to it
it'll just create heat right it'll it'll
create like a violent reaction just
explode
but it's kind of it's it's nuts it
should be more than enough to take out
the incredible hulk having it in a
gaseous form is a way for her to just
kind of
envelope the hulk the problem with this
is he completely inhales her
right he completely inhales like this
sulfuric acid gas
and then just spits it back in the face
of another member of the ufos right and
the problem is like simon literally
starts choking and dying on this stuff
right like that's kind of the crazy
thing the overall gist of this is that
because of the the
really the power of the immortal hulk
here he's able to overcome these guys
quite readily and the result of this is
that they kind of just whisk him away
right literally he just gets punched
across
like across the sky right across the
land and ultimately the ufos end up
contacting hiring garrick and it's just
like okay look we kind of had him on the
ropes
they didn't and it's like if your guys
hadn't screwed up then like we would
have ultimately gotten a hold of him
we would have been able to bring him in
the problem with this is they're like
we're not a match for him now right like
whatever
form he's in now is not enough for us to
be able to take this guy out
we need something more and that's when
henry peter geyrick basically
ends up getting a hold of the avengers
and has the avengers respond
so following that you essentially pick
up in manhattan and of course immortal
hulk's not too worried about the ufos at
the moment it's just kind of like you
know
like whatever right i mean they're going
to come after me they come after me and
i'll give them more the same right i
mean you know that's that's kind of the
crazy thing and so in the midst of this
kind of thing where he's just kind of
standing in this bar
one of the things to remember when it
comes to the hulk is that society at
large is still fearful of him even
though the the immortal hulk is kind of
is really more intelligent and kind of
wants to be left alone to a degree
different things like that this version
not necessarily the immortal hulk but a
more intelligent version of the hulk is
essentially powered by the mind of of
joe fix it
at the end of the day people are still
terrified of the hulk right the fear
still reigns supreme and that's why you
see this kind of
crazy thing when it's just like you know
people are horrified by this guy the
problem is that in the middle of all
this
thor shows up and immediately attacks
the immortal hulk right immediately goes
after him and this is one of those
things where the response to the
avengers seems to be more or less
containment right the idea that like the
immortal hulk is probably going to go on
a rampage again and that's the overall
assumption whenever it comes to the hulk
whenever the hulk appears
unless there's some kind of a situation
with like the onslaught saga where he's
necessary and the avengers like
call the hulk in or some kind of
situation like that whenever he's just
kind of
out there the assumption is he's about
to go and you know cause craziness and
all kinds of stuff so the avengers
respond accordingly but there's actually
something else sort of going on here
something else is actually happening but
the funny thing is that
thor despite the power that he possesses
is just not enough
for the immortal hulk now this is
something that i want to point out here
what this looks like and we can't
definitively say this because they look
a little bit different but what this
looks like is the version of thor who
currently rules asgard and if that's the
case
thor has his equivalent of the odin
force now i wouldn't go as far as to say
this is like
immortal hulk fighting odin and so like
immortal hulk can beat odin but he's
more powerful than your baseline version
of force and that's the whole
significance behind this is this is the
power boost
that the immortal hulk got not only that
it's all the avengers that are here
and this is why i say this is probably
king thor's because you've got them the
current roster of the avengers who are
here
the reality of this is even despite
their best efforts there's not a whole
lot that they can do to make things
even more difficult you've got the
arrival of red harpy betty who shows up
here which is basically like another
gamma irradiated mutate i mean we had a
discussion on her previously
so make sure you guys check the uh the
immortal hulk playlist down in the
description so you can get caught up and
you can really you can find out more
about who she is
but what you end up getting here is
essentially like this this
red god hulk facing off against like the
avengers and that's kind of the nuts
thing is because this whole
situation is kind of looked at and
really even narrated by like jennifer
walters by she-hulk now there really
isn't a whole lot she could do anyway
against this level of power i mean
there's not really even anything the
like like thor or like iron man or
captain america black panther or even
captain marvel could do against this but
at the end of the day she's kind of
narrating it and she's just like all the
incredible hulk knows
is rage and chaos right that's all this
thing knows that's all it's known over
the course of its life that ever since
the whole came into existence all it's
known is being chased and tracked down
by various people that is
it's like these small moments of
reprieve when he finds a kind of
ally in the avengers but for the most
part it's always somebody hunting him
down somebody attacking him somebody
coming against him and and really
jennifer walters sees
this version of of the hulk as kind of
like the epitome right this idea of the
hulk's rage
given form now this almost kind of seems
to fly in the face of world breaker hulk
but that's one of the funny things to
keep in mind
is even though world breaker hulk was
the strongest version of the hulk that
we'd seen
the reality was that his rage had
reached a point where it was almost a
kind of
inner calm right it was almost a point
where he was just kind of had reached
like a stillness like you ever had that
where you get so pissed off that you're
just calm
right and that's almost like the the
scariest version of a person being mad
where they just kind of stop and calm
down and it's like oh my god right like
it's about to pop off man like
[Laughter]
that's kind of the crazy thing and
that's why you even see references to
like
world breaker hulk where you kind of
have this scenario where blade is
basically like thrown into the sky
by hulk and then the response of captain
america he tells iron man go get him and
and iron man's like well i mean no like
i mean you guys can't stand against a
hulk on your own and at the end of the
day like black panther is like no we
retain the
the the advantage of numbers right like
a single warrior
is you know that's disciplined enough
can handle the hulk on their own and
that's when whole kind of comments and
says like you know like you're you're
disciplined enough like if you're
disciplined how'd that work out for you
last time you know and that's what uh
black panther is like like i offered you
mercy but like i attempted dialogue
you taught me a lesson when you crushed
us all so badly that's what's so kind of
crazy about this right it's literally
learning lessons from their experiences
facing off against the hulk and so what
you end up getting in the middle of this
huge fight where the avengers are quite
literally just
getting it handed to them is you have
the arrival of gamma flight now remember
gamma flight is really trying to reel
the hulk back in
but get a better understanding of what's
going on because behind the veil of
all of this and that's the thing that
jennifer walters does not initially pick
up on here but then starts to realize
it's kind of going on
behind the veil of all of this is the
one below all there's a kind of rage
that's permeating
everybody a kind of wrath that's even
permeating thor right something behind
the scenes is kind of tugging
and almost instigating right almost
increasing this kind of violence that
each of these heroes have towards the
incredible hulk
and the kind of rage he has towards them
and there's this kind of comment this
kind of moment where you have a titania
who approaches she-hulk with the
intention of trying to try to take her
out and the response of titania right
with gamma flight working alongside the
the hulk group more or less is
do we take out the she-hulk chick or or
like do we just let her stay
and the response of betty is no like
she's with us right like you've seen the
door haven't you and the response of
she-hulk is
yes i've seen the green door so she's
aware that the green door exists now
whether or not she knows what lies
beyond it
isn't really explained here we assume
that maybe she does but at the end of
the day the effects of the one below all
kind of permeate out into everything so
much so that there's actually a point
where thor
like smashes the hand of the immortal
hulk with mjolnir and then doing that
literally just like destroys his arm
right like literally just fractures his
arm and then following that like
immortal hulk just takes the tentacles
or the
little bits of his arm that are there
and starts to suffocate thor and it's
one of the things that jennifer walters
kind of hits on is that like
thor's not normally like this right he's
not normally this extreme and aggressive
that's not usually how he is right he's
he
he can be if he needs to be but it's
almost like thor's in a berserker state
but not in a berserker state that the
response of thor would be one of
containment and control
not like assault and and almost like an
attempt to kill and that's the whole
thing behind the avengers is
understanding the immortal hulk as he
exists in the sense that he can always
kind of be resurrected and always come
back
and their experiences facing off against
him in the past in his most powerful
forms
really leads them to the position of we
gotta take him out black panther
literally cuts his arm off i mean it's
just
it's things like that right it's it's
really extreme in a lot of ways
the fight that's going on here but
that's when jennifer walters even looks
at black panther and realizes okay so
black panther is not necessarily
governed by rage here but the steps he's
taking
are even a little extreme for him right
where he just kind of looks at hulk and
it's just like we have to kill him right
like we have to kill this guy and that's
usually not the response of black
panther like the only time black panther
really takes a response like that is
it's like somebody invades wakanda or
they're like an
imminent threat to wakanda or even like
the world or something like that then
black panther will take that approach
like we need to kill them and while
there is recognition here that black
panther is operating in a more
calculated form he's offering
operating in a more methodical form even
then it just seems
chaos right it seems like chaos and
pandemonium and so ultimately you end up
having betty who approaches she-hulk and
she doesn't go to attack she just kind
of looks at her with this expectation of
are you going to do anything about this
and that's when she hulk seemingly has
to choose her allegiance she's at this
point where she kind of has to choose
the hulk family or she has to choose the
avengers and the reality is that it
makes sense here
because of the fact that she was really
the last hold out and that's what makes
things kind of intriguing because one
thing to bear in mind we're like three
issues out from the conclusion of al
ewing's run
so who knows what form this is gonna
take but the reality is she's part of
the hulk family whether she wants to
admit it or not
whether she sees herself that way or not
she definitively is and so she basically
quells the entirety of the conflict with
just one of those sonic claps and sends
the avengers all flying and so in
response to that a kind of teleportation
gun is ultimately fired and that
basically allows uh gamma flight
and the and the hulks to essentially
take off right to basically bail out
and that's when uh that's when she-hulk
ends up going with them and so in
essence
she-hulk has now stood against the
avengers and she's now currently
operating alongside the incredible hulk
family more or less that's kind of nuts
because basically
everybody who's irradiated with gamma
mutation is now aligned on a particular
side right this is probably the most
true statement if there's ever been one
of a of really an entire hulk family
right that's
really what it is here but i'm kind of
curious like what direction this is
going to go in like i'm curious where
we're going to end up seeing this kind
of conclude but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section about al ewing's
run so far
and i will catch you all later peace